uh welcome Alexander it seems like you
know we are in Paris you are at home and
you're coming turkey every day so you
just won your second game an incredibly
complicated game and what a move through
k6 uh guide us through the game today
just a few key points first of all why
didn't you take Bishop B3 why did you
decide uh to play 96 well I didn't
remember of course anything in the
opening and I I just went for this uh
opposite colored bishop and game I
decided to play it safe
and I think the position was about equal
um probably I mean she could have played
better she missed some
tactical small tactical possibilities
like when she played Rook before a
little bit later on yeah here
Rook C3 Rook B6 I think yeah it's not
I'm in here
probably she she wanted to just repeat
the position but I you know I dared to
play on
yes I played rookie three and of course
it's still pretty equal and I hesitated
for a very long time after Bishop E6
whether to repeat the position or not
here because yes it was some kind of
repetition but I decided to play on and
uh yes but did you feel that she lost
the thread of the game
here uh well it's already pretty like
safe after the pawn moved to E4 I'm not
in danger to lose my opponent D6 or at
least it felt pretty safe and I didn't
think that I'm risking anything to play
on till time control and then yeah
immediately uh like um yeah here she let
me take on A6 and even though I mean it
should be holdable I don't know but
somehow
again I thought that if I don't
sacrifice it's going to be more
difficult for me to play because she is
going to take on C4 and I need to defend
and here she needs to defend I didn't
see how to save the position how to save
the game because G5 G5 I'll just show
one line yeah D5 C takes D5 and probably
she means that if she plays Rook G3 well
at least I hope that I can play D6
G6 is also possible yes C4
G6 C3
G7 C2 Bishop F4 E3 Bishop takes history
Rook Texas three King D2 Rook E8 and
then here D7 Rook G8 and H4
but I think I'm in time I don't know why
it just shows ah because it's Rook
versus queen okay but King B6 H5 King C7
H6 and I'm in time to protect the spawn
on G7
and yeah it seems that I should be like
winning here
um so it's gonna be like a rook versus
ah I see Rook G2 and King Sivan I don't
know the evolution of this position
should be winning no well I hope so I
mean yeah but still uh but it shows the
depth of your calculation and of how
many variations do you see during the
game it's really impressive so I think
that it was a total shock for your
opponent Did You observe uh harika when
you played the move uh Rook A6 no I mean
I think she noticed it and uh I mean she
took it pretty calmly but again after G5
yeah I don't know what to do what black
should do instead of D5 because my plan
yeah but then I was going to play kinky
too I'm thinking about just playing
king2 and kinky three kinky four and you
know my plan is very very easy and
whether it's holdable or not it's an
interesting question so
that was a very important Victory
Alexandra I know that you shared
well that you want to win this
tournament at least once so we still
have seven rounds to go but uh well
catch me if you can as I told before so
I hope that you will continue your
winning streak yeah I hope so
our congratulations Alexandra a very
very nice Victory indeed